in your uh book a beautiful question you
ask
does the world embody beautiful ideas so
the book is centered around this
very interesting question it's like
shakespeare you can like dig in and read
into all the different interpretations
of this question
but at the high level what to use the
connection between
beauty of the world and physics of the
world
in a sense we now have a lot of insight
into what the laws are the for
the form they take that and allow us to
understand
matter in great depth and control it
as we as we've discussed uh and
it's an extraordinary thing how
mathematically ideal
those equations turn out to be in
the early days of greek philosophy
plato had this model of atoms built out
of
the five perfectly symmetrical platonic
solids so there was
somehow the idea that mathematical
symmetry
uh should govern the world and uh we've
outplated plato
by far in modern physics because
we have symmetries that are much more
extensive much more powerful
that turn out to be uh the ingredients
out of which we construct our theory of
the world
and and it works and uh
so that's certainly beautiful so the the
the math
the idea of symmetry which is uh a
driving
inspiration in much of human art
especially a decorative art or like the
alhambra
or in wallpaper designs or things you
see around you everywhere
also turns out to be the dominant theme
in
modern fundamental physics symmetry and
its manifestations
the laws turn out to be very to have
these tremendous amounts of symmetry you
can change
the symbols and move them around in
different ways and they still have
the same consequences uh
that so that's that's
uh beautiful and uh
that that uh these things uh these
different
these concepts that humans find
appealing
also turn out to be the concepts that
govern how the world actually works
and uh i don't think that's an accident
i think
the humans were evolved to be able to
interact with the world in
in ways that are advantageous and to
learn from it
and so we are naturally evolved or
designed to enjoy beauty and
and it's a symmetry and this and the
world has it and that's no
that's why we what's why we resonate
with it
well it's interesting that the ideas of
symmetry emerge at all
at many levels of
the hierarchy of the universe
so you're talking about particles but it
also is
at the level of chemistry and biology
and
um and the fact that our
cognitive sort of our perception system
and whatever
our cognition is also finds it appealing
or somehow our sense of what is
beautiful is grounded in this idea of
symmetry or the breaking of symmetry
symmetry is at the core of our
conception of beauty whether it's the
breaking or the non-breaking of the
symmetry
it makes you wonder why
why like uh so i come from russia
in the question of dostoyevsky he's
he has said that beauty will save the
world maybe
maybe as a physicist you can tell me
what do you think he meant by that
i don't i don't know if it saves the
world but it does turn out to be a
tremendous source of insight into the
world
when we uh investigate kind of the
the most fundamental interactions things
that are
hard to access because they occur at
very short distances between
very uh
special kinds of particles whose
properties are only revealed at high
energies
uh we don't have much to go on from
everyday life
but so we have when we guess what the so
we and then the experiments are
difficult to do
so you can't you can't really uh follow
a very uh wholly empirical procedure to
sort of step in the baconian style
figure out the laws kind of step by step
just by accumulating a lot of data
what we actually do is guess and the
guesses are kind of
aesthetic really what what would be a
nice description
that's consistent with what we know and
then you try it out and see if it works
and then
and by gosh it does in in some
in many profound cases uh so
there's that but there's another source
of symmetry which i
didn't talk so much about in
in a beautiful question but does
relate to your comments and i think very
much relates to
the source of of symmetry that we find
in biology
and uh in
in our in our heads you know in our
brain which is that
uh although i'd well i
it is discussed a bit in in uh a
beautiful question and and
also in fundamentals is that
when you have
symmetry is also a very important uh
means of construction
so when you have for instance simple
viruses
that that need to construct their coat
their protein coat the coats often take
the form of platonic solids
and the reason is that the viruses are
really dumb
and they only know how to do one thing
so they make a pentagon then they make
another pentagon they make another
pentagon and they
all glue together in the same way and
that makes a very symmetrical
object sort of so the rules of
development when you have simple rules
and they
go they work again and again you get
symmetrical patterns that's it's kind of
in fact it's a recipe also for
generating
fractals you know oh really like
the kind of broccoli that has all this
internal structure and i
wish i had a picture to ship that many
people remember it from the
from the uh from the supermarket
and you say how did a vegetable get so
intelligent to make such a beautiful
object of all this
fractal structure and the the the secret
is stupidity
you just do the same thing over and over
again and
uh in our brains also you know we've we
came out we start from single cells
and they reproduce and they they're each
one
does basically roughly the same thing
they
the program evolves in time of course
different
different modules get turned on and off
genetic
different regions of the genetic code
get turned on and off
but uh but basically a lot of the same
things are going on and they're simple
things and so you produce the same
patterns over and over again and that's
a recipe for producing symmetry because
you're getting the same thing
in many many places and if you look at
uh
for instance the beautiful drawings of
rahman ikahal the great neuroanatomist
who drew the structure of different
organs like
the hippocampus you see it's very
regular
and very intricate and
it's symmetry in in this
in in that sense it's because it's it's
it's many repeated units that that
uh you can take from one place to the
other and see that they look more or
less the same
you